thank you gentlemen Robert Eggers okay
thanks
I've made two feature films and some
short films nobody's seen and so it's
still strange to me that anyone cares
what I might have to say is yeah but
anyway thank you very much and thanks to
BAFTA it's it's truly an honor to to be
here I've never lectured before and
perhaps it's just the word lecture but I
it makes me anxious I feel comfortable
public speaking the only training I have
is as an actor and my theater background
makes me happy to be in front of an
audience I feel I do feel more
comfortable here than at a cocktail
party luckily there's cocktails and I
have one here just in case so you know
III but I'm really looking forward to
the conversation later because a Q&A is
where I feel I thrive a little more I
almost thought about just asking myself
a series of questions up here to make
myself feel more comfortable but I will
spare you that strangeness so I want to
say as you all know the most important
thing we can do as people who are trying
to make creative work is to be yourself
and embrace what is uniquely you and
your own voice
so obviously I'm just talking about my
approach and and I and it's and it's
unique just the kind of strange
interests that I have and I I just hope
that there's some tools that you can put
in your toolbox that can work with how
you are you I also want to say that as
many of the
other incredibly accomplished filmmakers
that III it's an honor to be among in
this series I'm a writer and director so
the way that I write my screenplays is
would be inappropriate if I weren't
directing them as an actor who recently
turned down a role in one of my movies
said that the screenplay was overwrought
and and there is a kind of indulgence in
the details of my screenplays that would
be entirely foolish if I was writing for
another director there's a level of
specificity in the blocking you know if
Willem Dafoe wears his reading glasses
like this if Robert Pattinson scratches
his ear like this it may very well be in
the screenplay
there's never in my screenplay Rome
burns or they fight you know Arthur
draws xcalibur he thrusts towards the
Giant to parries and you know the whole
thing so so there okay so that out of
the way I'll start at the beginning yeah
again this feels so odd but you know
what what what what's what's the
inspiration where where do the ideas
come from to write something it depends
on the on the script as I'm sure you
would all agree IIIi had an incredibly
intense nightmare many years ago that
led to the idea of a story I walked
around Brooklyn for five hours and and
had the structure of a screenplay that
took me six years to write that was
terrible but you know I just kind of had
it most often I have an atmosphere which
I'll talk about a lot later and some
images that get me going and sometimes
it's something pragmatic
I did and and and very often it's a
combination of a few of these things I
made a short film called brothers
that was a proof of concept to try to
get the witch financed I had been many
years since I'd made a short film and my
most recent work was a very stylized
piece based on Edgar Allan Poe which
featured a puppet as a lead character
and performances that were truly weird
and my producer said you know if you
wanted anyone to finance to which you
probably ought to make a new short and
it should feature naturalistic
performances by children and scary woods
and so that was a task you know and and
so and and thus I was able to find a
story that met with that pragmatic task
with with the which I I had written many
feature screenplays that no one wanted
to finance and I felt that as an
American director at the time if I
wanted to get a film finance it seemed
like it needed to be in an identifiable
genre all of my sort of weirder films no
one cared for so I thought well probably
have to take place in New England
because that's where I'm from
and given that I'll probably have no
budget I'll have to shoot it and like
the proverbial my parents backyard and
witches are the archetypal New England
spook and I've been interested them in
them so that makes sense so there's the
pragmatic end but then I truly as a kid
and this sounds a little precious but I
really did imagine the fact that there
were Puritans walking around who grew up
in the reign of Queen Elizabeth who were
you know chomping around the woods
behind my house and and that was and
living an almost medieval existence and
you pair that with the belief in a real
witch and that was an atmosphere that
really excited me you know with with
with the lighthouse similarly my brother
said he was working on a ghost story in
a lighthouse and that
a ghost story in a lighthouse conjured
up the images of the movie the the
visual atmosphere the crusty musty dusty
rusty black and white square aspect
ratio and and then I needed to find a
story that accompanied that so anyway
all of these things really finally have
to do with what I'm really interested in
and what is sort of uniquely me I think
maybe which is my interest in in in
ghost stories fairy tales folk tales
mythology religion sometimes the occult
that's what really gets me excited I
would rather write a novel or paint a
painting that has to do with that stuff
than to just make a movie and and and
all that really has to do with the past
which weirdly may somehow be my my
biggest passion I think that there's
complicated things about organized
religion but there's also complicated
things about like in an entirely
secularized society we lose the the
sublime and and the sacred sometimes and
so I find that what what really excites
me is to kind of understand where we're
coming from and where we're going from
where we where we came from and and and
to try to go back into the past to think
about ideas that are bigger than
ourselves the genre that tends to
explore that today is science fiction
which makes sense when like you know
number is is God and in the like you
know intelligentsia that we're probably
a part of but I I like to stay in in the
past and what's very important to me
when I begin writing a piece is to not
have a message to not have any intention
beyond staying true to the world in
which I'm trying
- - right in so but but but thank
heavens like as much as I try to seal
myself up like an anchorite or and lock
myself in my alchemical cell you know
the world is not my world is not vacuum
sealed so I am affected by the zeitgeist
whether I want to be or or not and if
and that's important because otherwise
you know the witch can't just appeal to
people who are alive in the 1630s and
the lighthouse can't just appeal to
people who are alive in the 1890s
because there's not enough graveyard
screenings for that to be profitable so
you know with the witch I'm happy that
that that most people though not
everyone for sure sees the film as a
feminist film if I were to be objective
and stand back I think I would agree
with that stance but that was not my
intention I just wanted to make a witch
movie as I kind of said and and and but
but but but that's what happened with
with the lighthouse which I don't know
if people have seen you know I was just
trying to make a ghost story in the
lighthouse which it's finally not but it
became you know when I was writing this
story this hyper-masculine story about
two men with my brother I was thinking
this is why are we writing this right
now this is the worst time to be writing
this story and then once we had the
first draft we realized like oh I guess
we're talking about toxic max
masculinity and like everything that's
like messed up about it so so that's
that's cool and you know but but but but
but but even still when you're getting
into this this other world you know you
can't be judgmental of the characters
and the time period you can't rewrite
history to to to conform to the
zeitgeist but you do have a
responsibility to understand what's
going on today and not be foolhardy the
the thing that I'm working on currently
has slavery and violence against women
and and it's takes place in the Viking
Age so that's going to happen but how do
I tell those stories
without rewriting history responsibly I
don't you know those are the questions I
have to ask myself and I can't provide
easy answers so continuing to stay quite
large a few things that I think about
and struggle with is trying to find a
harmonious balance of certain opposites
in my writing the the largest things
would be like I you know Dionysian
versus Apollonian the sort of there or
or I'll start with Apollonian which is
you know the the the structure the what
what patriarchy or patriarchal Western
culture would call like male ideals and
then the diet the Dionysian female
mysterious the stuff like how do you
create a balance of something that is
like rigorous and and structured and and
and clear but also has enigma and
mystery and atmosphere moving further it
with with these opposites the mythic
versus the naturalistic I'm again I'm
drawn to archetypal storytelling I'm
drawn to archetypal characters how do
you make them believable it's it's it's
it's it's difficult in in in doing this
kind of archetypal storytelling even if
it's based on a fairy tale or a myth I
still try to bring in you know my
personal experiences the things that
aren't me when my brothers first read
the witch screenplay they said you know
even though this is the 17th century it
sounds like our family arguing you know
Manette's and that's that's very
important you know someone not just
conveying plot but but but also having
little asides that are about life like
these kinds of things can of course
ground it and and another thing that
really helps me
which is not surprising is is knowing
the space like when I when I write it's
very helpful for me to kind of have a
dollhouse and dolls and their clothing
and know what's in each room and in
order for me to like really imagine
what's what's going on and also because
I'm telling stories that take place in
the past and aren't my personal
experience by creating this dollhouse in
my head and with mood boards and such
like I'm able to see it clearly enough
to own it because if I can't experience
what I write as my own memories I I
can't be truthful again that's sort of a
precious statement but but that's how I
try to look at it it's taking every
moment on as if this is a moment from my
personal past and in order to tell it
another one of these opposites for me is
atmosphere versus story all you need to
make a film that's incredibly engaging
is an excellent script with a great
story and serviceable performances they
don't even have to be good they just
have to be serviceable you don't need
good cinematography you don't need good
art direction you don't need good
costumes
you don't need good sound design you
have to have professional sound so it's
not distracting but it's really about
that script but for me both my two
feature films have very simple stories
the witches has a very clear simple
story the lighthouse is almost void of
story
it's almost the same scene over and over
and over and over and over again with
changing power dynamics so in in my in
my films like you need atmosphere for
the world to survive for the film to
survive and the atmosphere you know is
an accumulation of details and these
details come from my research they come
from from the weather they come from the
light they come from you know
the format that we shoot on they come
they come from all of these things and
and and and and an atmosphere like in
some ways is a is a visual obstacle this
and I mean that in a positive way
Emmanuel Lubezki aka Chivo obviously I
couldn't admire him more and but he's
very excited about shooting this isn't
writing sorry but he's very excited
about shooting Alexis 65 and and he has
a quote kind of saying that we that in
the history of cinema we've been looking
at the world through dirty windows and
finally now like we can see the world
clearly with Alexis 65 and like
technology
I like the dirty windows you know like I
like having to peer in through something
that excites me so we'll we'll get
further into like when I really start
talking about period research we'll get
further and into atmosphere and details
and and and the research process but I'd
like to play the first clip all the
clips are a little long so sorry
[Music]
killeth God give you good Mora oh let's
do it bad save mother there's no Easter
eyes on the dry day
it's hard for me to watch the witch
because it just didn't it doesn't always
quite live up to my expectations we had
to shoot it digitally for financial
reasons and I'm glad that we did but it
does you know like the irony is I'm
using that as an example of atmosphere
yeah I find it to be quite naked dick
Pope was talking about Mike Lee's
Peterloo which I thought was a
fine-looking digital film and dick Pope
like myself would finds it blasphemous
to add film grain if you're shooting
with the Alexa but he added a bit more
digital noise and I wish that we had had
that idea with the witch but in any case
that is you know an example of the kind
of atmosphere that I'm trying to create
and all of the goat bleats and the and
the dirty stockings and the rushes on
the floor and all that stuff is very
carefully and the creaking ladder rungs
is all very carefully described in the
screenplay again like that kind of
detail in the screenplay might be
laborious but I feel like in my movies
that are sometimes like thin on plot
like if you can't like get that
atmosphere from the text like we don't
have any understanding of what I'm of
what I'm trying to do here I very often
describe the odors in my screenplays as
well in order so that we can better
convey that feeling when we watch it the
other thing that's important potentially
about this clip is it's kind of showing
the audience my dollhouse I think that
it's not always important for the
audience to know
but in this clip and in the next clip we
we are we you know that kind of the
geography of of their cottage was
important and so early on in the film
were establishing the atmosphere and the
mood and then and then we were showing
the layout of a little delay of the land
so to speak and the same thing will
happen with the next clip from from from
the lighthouse but you know going back
to like pragmatism and maybe we'll talk
about producer and studio notes at some
point in the QA cuz that's another
interesting topic but you know with the
film was supposed to start not I don't
know if everyone's like seeing the witch
or not but basically the film was
supposed to start not much further back
from that and my my producers and
financier is wanted me to start earlier
like in with them leaving the village or
the plantation that they came from which
I thought was ridiculous and I didn't
want to be doing like Little House on
the Prairie and and I so I wrote a scene
sort of that I thought would be too
expensive that we couldn't shoot and
then everyone loved it and then we had
to find a way to like fit it into the
budget and you know and I kept trying to
cut it out of the movie but actually
they were right we didn't we didn't need
it
so sometimes studio notes are good okay
let's watch the next clip
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
he continued he goes upstairs and he
sees more but you know we got to get on
with tonight as far as you know the
dollhouse goes so that it was about four
minutes and that was four pages of
writing which is I mean it could easily
have been a page like boat comes season
Island get off the boat they walk across
the thing they stand there he goes in he
walks around whatever you know but it
but but again it's this overwrought
writing of every detail for four pages
but it also gives you know a better
understanding of exactly what we're
shooting how long things are gonna take
and and it helps I feel like it helps my
collaborators under understand like what
we're doing even that long close-up of
the two of them standing with the eye
line towards camera was a very hefty
paragraph about what we were supposed to
convey from their faces in that in that
moment so let's get into something
that's actually interesting so you know
researching the period is my whole thing
and you know there's nothing better
about being period-accurate but it's
something that really excites me and if
there is anything like you know I said
that my interest in ghost stories and
fairy tales whatever perhaps is unique
about me but if there's anything unique
about my films it's perhaps like my
obsession with being accurate of course
you know Bram Stoker's Dracula and Peter
Brooks King Lear are fantastic examples
of films aren't period-accurate in any
way shape or form but take you into
incredibly rich transport of believable
worlds I guess Dracula's kind of
stylized but it's great and for me you
know I'd like to I like it when I don't
understand these people I like it when
I'm researching Puritans and I think how
and could this kind of English Calvinism
be hope
for anyone and then be reading and
reading and reading struggling like this
these are these are alien thoughts these
are alien people and finally you know
reading John Wooden thrips letters to
his wife back home in England and that
they were like praying at the same time
they didn't know about time zones but
you know they thought they were praying
at the same time and and and and things
like that all of a sudden you see okay
they're human like me and finally you
can unlock this door where you realize
like oh my goodness like if I was alive
then I would have thought exactly like
them of course I would have and not only
that like I can see how they're that
kind of thinking still resonates in
culture today that for me is the most
exciting moment so when so and that
requires a lot of reading and and and
then you you know in in the creation of
the physical world which also begins in
this in the script phase you know I'm
also looking at like tons of visual
imagery to understand all this stuff
because again the atmosphere is an
accumulation of details and if I were to
be creating a fictional world perhaps if
I was like junior our Tolkien and was
that kind of genius at that kind of time
in my hands I could create something
that's specific but generally it's not
going to be as specific as the real
thing so if I'm just taking research and
not and saying this is exactly what it
is team let's recreate it to the best of
our ability we have a huge amount of
detail more detail than than we could
have if we had conjured it up ourselves
at least that's my thinking and so you
know you read secondary sources you read
primary sources you read children's
books on it to get like another base
overview after you've already gone deep
you watched crappy YouTube videos you
just you go into museums you consult
with historians you
do whatever needs to be done to find out
as much as you possibly can and you know
with the lighthouse for example it's all
built on research so my brother's had a
ghost story in a lighthouse that was
inspired imagery then on day 2 of
researching I read about smalls
lighthouse tragedy two guys both named
Thomas one older one younger they get
marooned in their lighthouse station
because of a storm and the old one dies
the young one goes mad that's my story
that's the the dead that's the base of
my story and then you know the the
lighthouse keepers and the instruction
to lighthouse keepers the manual that
becomes a huge key this all the tasks
that they're doing and the rules that
they're not supposed to break that
becomes inspiration for all kinds of
scenes and then the photographs of 19th
century lighthouse stations tell you a
whole lot not just about my dollhouse
but more you see the boathouse with
runners and a lifeboat in it well I
guess at some point broad patents gonna
try to escape and pull that lifeboat out
you know and so all that stuff is
incredibly helpful and then we you know
we continue to amplify our knowledge in
these different areas I'm saying we
because I wrote this with my brother and
in considering Melville which you would
if you're writing a new a New England
19th century maritime story you start
getting into classical mythology we
start getting into classical mythology
you started thinking about symbolist
painting from the period and and so
Sasha Schneider and John Daleville who
are doing like mythic paintings in a
homoerotic style become perfect
candidates as imagery that's going to
work itself into the script in writing
period dialogue it's the same kind of
rigor with the which I I felt that I
don't know if I agree with his conceit
today but I felt that because the
Puritans were so
these word again rigorous in their
beliefs so so devout that I felt I
needed to use their own words to be
respectful to them I don't know if that
I agree with that now and I think it
might have been disrespectful to use
their own words but that's what I did
and like luckily because as early modern
English that's the period of Milton and
Shakespeare and Spenser
so there's many books about and and
thesauruses with the vocabulary and the
rules which was incredibly helpful but I
also read tons and tons and tons and
tons of primary source material and made
my own thesaurus that wasn't a
one-to-one but sort of like a vibe so
things you might say when you're
chastising your children things you
might say when you think you're done is
at which things you might say to your
goat would and and and so you kind of
are pulling from from all these
different things and some of the
dialogue early on became a bit of a
collage that then I need to like hone
into the separate voices for different
characters and and make it much more
specific and mine but there were things
that the children said when they are
possessed are things that I that
children supposedly said when they were
possessed and that was at the time I
wrote this important to me but very
often in my research like I something
would inspire a scene so John Winthrop
the first governor of Massachusetts who
I mentioned earlier he has a very
personal religious diary that was a real
treasure trove for me and he wrote that
he dreamed quote that he was that I was
with Christ upon the earth and that very
instant with them in many tears for the
assurance of the pardon of my sins
etc I was so ravished with his love
towards me far exceeding the affection
of the kindest husband that being
awakened it had made so deep an
impression in my heart as I was forced
to unmeasurable weeping for a great
while and had a more lively feeling of
love than ever before so in this next
clip
to take that it inspired a scene with
the mother and the witch and she uses
half of that and she uses it to a
different end the other dialogue and the
scene with her and her husband is very
much a fight that I might have with my
wife
or a fight that my parents might have
had only in early modern English and I
apologize if Kate Dicky's Scottish tinge
to Archer accent is a bit tricky to
understand but at least them in the UK
and not the states let's do it
just remember John cancel that first
winter he was tormented of Indian magic
she's not the same this is unnatural
providence I know not that look at my
son will what think you think what think
I have no thoughts
this is not what what witchcraft which
no sister no I thought through as a
child are you doing we're back to the
plantation in Amman find a good family
for Thomasin looks like Caleb to the
doctors he'll tell if this be some
natural ill enough
yeah we cannot return his baggage I'll
scour the field that must be some fruit
yeah untouched by this rot I was a staff
and what comes out there for him
presently
we all bear it to the village we know
horse well the little corn and the gull
should try to find rice well well back
with Caleb and sell them return with
your [ __ ] for the twins in summer said
he cannot weigh them here but Thomas in
ins they forget that Rockwell wants what
does that want Catherine tell me and I
will give it though I want to be home
thou shalt be home by candle times Amana
in England
oh well I also have a confession to make
I never meant to be assured to me I have
big Alma's jobs why even know it
since Samson my heart's turned to stone
I hate dream ones does when I was of
Thomasson Jews then I was with Christ
upon earth ah I was so very near him and
in many tears for the assurance of the
pardon of me sins and I was so ravaged
with his love towards me and since some
you'll disappear I have such a sad
weakness of faith I cannot shake it I
cannot see cries help is me I pray and I
pray but I cannot I fear I cannot ever
feel that same nature of love again
oh sure Avada in heaven
I'll be afield if you can spout a while
do believe it dawn I promise it up I do
like the performances Alexa or not but
but yeah so there's an example of that
in in the lighthouse by brother and I
did not very very rarely used in intact
sentences we we were studying all kinds
of things to create two different
Forgotten New England dialects from the
end of the 19th century
I mentioned Melville Stevenson is not
from New England but certainly with some
of the maritime stuff he felt he could
come in handy and Coleridge to all the
usual culprits but then of course we
turn to lighthouse keepers journals and
Diaries and that was very fruitful for
Robert Pattinson's character as a former
lumberjack I found a treasure trove of
interviews with former Lumberjacks from
that period but who became the most
helpful was a writer named Sarah Orne
Jewett and she was writing in the state
of Maine in in in our period and she was
very concerned concerned or interested
in dialect herself and so she would be
interviewing sailors and sea captains
and farmers and then writing her main
stories in phonetic dialect so that was
the key and Dafoe has a couple sentences
like when he's wistfully thinking about
the past that come from Jewett but other
than that my brother and I were working
with all this source material and
various slang dictionaries
nineteenth-century slang dictionary
separated into region and and and
nautical dictionaries and lexicons to
really create something or our best
version to recreate something and my
wife
a dissertation by a woman named Evelyn
star Cutler who and her dissertation was
on dialect in Jewett and thank you
Evelyn
because she she she she provided rules
and we had those I had those rules when
I was writing the witch but but who if
not for Evelyn would have provided rules
for how to work in class people in in
the menorah theast of America would have
spoken so she was able to break it down
and talk about what words are omitted
and where there's Rohtak displacement
and so on and so forth so we could make
sure that these twelve things were
always consistent with Rob's character
and these ten with Willems or whatever
and it was very important you know when
we got to her but but from the beginning
we were writing and dialect before we
totally were fluent in it because we
were trying to get our minds to think
differently it was if you would write in
a in another language so so this next
clip it begins with quite naturalistic
dialogue or our attempt at it based on
our research but then Dafoe goes into a
kind of rant that I think it is a bit
theatrical like I'd like I I think that
you know the the the the influences of
Sam Sheppard and Pinter and like dare
I'd say out loud Beckett should show
themselves to be clear because even the
rant iasts ranter might not go on for
this long but it was fun what do you
call that sir
I'm up and swept twice over a lion dog I
swept the kids burg rhymed in the
dabbled unwiped unwashed in this stage
it's some kind of prayer out of
molesting me come now I already said how
dare you contradict me a dog now look
here
I ain't never intended to be no
housewife nor slave and taking this job
it ain't right
these Lord says is more ramshackle and
any shanty boys camp I ever seen the
queen of England's all fancy housekeeper
could even done no better than what I
done cuz I tell you I scrubbed this here
place twice old thing I say you did not
another sort and I say you swab it again
and you swab it proper like this time
and you'll be swabbing it ten times more
after that and if I entice you to pull
up in a part every floorboard and
clobbered of this here house and scour
I'm down with your bare bleeding
knuckles you'll do it and if I told you
to you go to every single nail from
every mold and nail all and suck off
every speck of rust till all their nails
sparkle like a sperm whale's pecker and
then carpenter the whole light station
back together from scrap and then do it
all over again your doors and by God and
by golly you do it smiling lad cuz you
like it you like it cuz I says you will
I'll predict me again and I'll dock your
wages you hear me lad
are you sir
soif dog swamp yeah so I don't know if
that's mythic but it's not naturalistic
either yeah you you know one thing that
I just didn't mention with the with the
research looking over my notes here is
just is the other thing is you're always
learning more and I'm and you're always
and I'm riding in tandem so I can
research some stuff write some stuff
research and stuff write some stuff the
whole time and you're constantly
revising as you find more clarity on
what the world is the the Viking script
was there was a tremendous amount of
research that I did my my co-writer
there is Icelandic and like really knows
a lot about Vikings but we have
consulted with three of the greatest
Viking historians recently and we missed
some stuff you know and and that means
that it's it's but it's tricky because
there are some things that you can say
okay like we'll fix this we'll fix this
but then it's like you know we've made
this sandcastle we have this glorious
tower that we're really proud of and we
have to smash it now it's horrifying but
sometimes you just have to like suck it
up and smash it and rebuild it better
so in conclusion that was a bit
scattered but hopefully during the QA we
can find a way to tie this all up in a
bow or maybe I'm exposing myself as
someone who's more interested in
atmosphere than story through the slash
okay
hi hi that was kind of incredible thank
you oh I'm glad I'm not even gonna try
and pretend to play intelligent
intelligence gymnastics with you so I'm
gonna maybe start and strip it all the
way back and start from layman's terms
in terms of process sure in everyday
terms yep
kind of just routine waking up in the
morning when the idea is in place when
it's in place is it already mapped out
in your head before you put pen to paper
yeah I think it's sort I think again
again it sort of depends if I'm writing
alone I be quite free I have up my
little notes about my 3x structure or my
5x structure depending on the piece that
I can kind of go back to and tweak but I
am sort of finding it as I go and I'm
allowing myself that if I'm writing for
a studio like if it you know I've never
written something like for hire but I
have been paid commissioned to write my
own piece and so therefore I do need to
have a treatment for the studio to be
sure that they actually like what
they're paying me to write but you know
with with with things on spec I will
just kind of let it happen when I'm
writing with another writer it's a it's
essential that we outline things very
clearly before we put pen to paper but
again things evolve and leave the whole
sandcastle metaphor whatever so I'm
writing with another writer that writing
with your brother on the right house
picking up on the idea of dialect and
naturalism in use even the last scene
we've just taken a look at there's a
poetry to it and rhythm to in a beat to
it yeah and how do you a create that in
a way that's communication between two
people and talking to it conversation
but then write that with another person
you I don't know you just do iiiiii
sorry I think I mean my brother and I
know each other pretty well we're
brothers so
that helps and I think you know in the
in both writing with my brother and with
the Icelandic poet and novelist young
who's a much better writer than I am
it's like I mean I I'm finally sort of
like in charge you know and that does
help clarify things though both of them
are incredibly talented I respect them
so much so if they're really telling me
like I've made a mistake I you know I
listen but I think it's you just kind of
toss things back and forth and I you
know with with my might with my brother
we are we're pretty well aligned on what
this what this was and I think sometimes
when we're working with with zone I tend
to like gild the lily and he tends to
say can take it back a bit with that
Nordic Sensibility um and with the
lighthouse he did kind of undersell it
in the way that you said that it was
just maybe every scene is a similar
conversation between two people a
different pathway and it's so not that
it's so kind of mental gymnastics a game
between the two of them and ever so
carefully and cleverly leads to this
incredible finale so the time of kind of
placing that and writing with your
brother again though seems to go how did
you kind of piece together a story an
arc and a narrative to get something
that you know essentially is two people
in one situation so I had that that
basic plot I mentioned from smalls white
house in Wales then you know very
quickly I was like okay there needs to
be mermaid in the movie she needs to be
washed up on shore at the midpoint and
there's a mystery in the light and
there's a foghorn and there's like all
these bits and bobs and I wrote some
stuff and then years passed and my
brother and I would like got together to
really write this thing so I gave max
the sort of 11 pages that I had written
all my notes I rewrote them in a way
that could be decipherable to another
human being and then I give him a list
of movies to watch and books to read and
a month later week
veined and started talking about how to
make sense of this and we talked and
talked and talked and talked and then
max wrote an outline and wasn't great
and max wrote another outline because I
was also writing two other things at the
time so that's the other thing is like I
like I really am enjoying collaborating
with other writers but I've found that
because the movie business is so tricky
if I don't have more than one thing
going at the same time I'm painting
myself into a corner so so so anyway
back to this so then max wrote a third
outline and act 1 and 2 were strong act
3 was not working we just couldn't find
it and but I said you know we're in good
enough shape so max break Act one so he
wrote Act one I revised it then he wrote
Act two I revised it and then I was so
excited that I wrote Act three and we
actually had like a movie and from there
we just passed it back and forth back
and forth but once we had had once we
had found that that first version like
we liked we realized that we had kind of
retold some some myths by mistake
another mistake but just by whatever by
the muses and that we were conjuring and
and so we said okay well let's let's
amplify our knowledge on prometheus and
Proteus and Triton and Neptune and then
see how we can further infuse the next
draft with our knowledge of all that
stuff and that led to some fairly heavy
handed imagery in the movie but
sometimes you just have to go with it
yeah yeah yeah you've kind of mentioned
as well when you were talking about the
idea that you have been researching
researching researching and then that
you're perhaps in kind of the 17th
century or the 19th century and to you
might not be resonating today but then
obviously it has resonated with
audiences today and thematically with
the witch and kind of being reporter in
the dark feminine
and with the lighthouse looking at toxic
masculine masculinity did you do you
realize that when you're writing that
this yeah no I was trying to say like
like no when you're done when you're
done writing like you can you can see it
but but not in I know I don't see it
well how important is it for you to have
kind of something that obviously isn't
so embedded in a specific time and space
but then can have some sort I thought
you said it's not about message but well
it's just like so I mean I'm after this
kind of archetypal story I can't know if
it's gonna work for forever but the best
stories stick around there's a reason
why people talk about Oedipus there's a
reason why people talk about Hamlet
there's a reason I'm not gonna keep
going but you know marie-louise von
Franz who was a prominent union said
that like Hans Christian Andersen's
fairy tales are going to die because
they aren't like essentially human the
way many of the Grimm fairy tales are
and that like Hans Christian Andersen
was like a demented Victorian and his
his stories are too wrapped up in his
Victorian repressions and whatever and
she's right like The Little Mermaid is
kind of sticking around thanks to Disney
but the Hans Christian Andersen fairy
tales are not being told at the same
frequency as they once were is the
lighthouse a grim fairy tale no but but
I guess the idea though is that you're
trying to have something that that
resonates in any time and I think by by
being by trying to have it be all about
the time period in which it's set in
instead of making any kind of
concessions for a contemporary audience
I feel like I have a stronger
chance of it being timeless because
obviously as much as I try to get and
into the mindset of the people of that
period it is slightly impossible so so
it finally is only going to be a mirror
of the mindset of today but and but you
know you using that the lens of the past
to reflect back on ourselves I mean
that's a little but I think you know
what I'm saying this dual spaces
interpretation because obviously can't
you ever know yeah you know um I'm gonna
skip in a little bit for in terms of
kind of the visual look and how that
relates back to the writing in terms of
looking at kind of the notion of four by
three do you have all of those things in
your head and in place when you begin
the writing process how does that affect
kind of the right and obviously the
claustrophobia of the lighthouse and how
is that having an impact on the way you
write yeah I mean the the aspect ratio
it got a little smaller over the years
but but I would always wanted it to be
boxy and I always wanted to be black in
like thirty five-millimeter that's
something when I that I saw when I
pictured the atmosphere and of course
like as you move forward both in the
writing and then in development and then
in prep you learn more things change you
know and your preconceived notions are
not always correct but but but you find
you make choices that are closer to your
original intentions even if they weren't
your preconceived notions about how to
articulate your intention and yeah so
sometimes I see how it's shot and and
sometimes in certain sequences I write
extremely wide shot lighthouse tender
like in the middle of the sea yadda
yadda yadda like close shot the hull
carves through waves like papa
sometimes I'll do that which again as a
writer director I can get away with
because it's a terrible thing to do
otherwise and sometimes I see that and I
don't write it because it's distracting
to the flow of the scene sometimes I
just see a scene a story and I know that
we're gonna have to find it later
sometimes I see a scene with that's a
complicated action sequence or stunt or
visual effect
practical effect and I think okay how
can I write this in an achievable way
and sometimes I think if you think about
writing it an achievable little way
you're not going to write it so just
write it and you'll figure it out and
you have to be blind to the realities of
shooting to tell the best story so then
coming back circling back to the idea of
studio Commission's or studio notes or
producer notes how does that then have
an impact I'm kind of writing in that
way and do you leave things out I'm not
I'm not I'm not duplicitous because the
the most important thing is that
everyone is on the same page because if
we can't if we don't like I try to now
after some experience say every horrible
thing that a studio wouldn't want to
hear about what I'm doing like straight
away and if they're scared at that point
like good you know but if they're but if
they're but if they're still willing to
listen after I've said like all the
crazy stuff then then then we're good to
go because I'm not gonna like shock them
too much as we as we move forward I
think you know I used to be very
defensive when I was younger and now I'm
not in the room but without I get my
notes I go home I see they're trying to
ruin my movie and I sleep on it and then
I realized actually these are smart I
think I think that you know like a lot
of times and this is i'm sure common
knowledge to you but a lot of times the
thoughts behind the note is right but
the note itself is not good I think you
know if you have multiple people saying
Singh is wrong with the scene maybe we
have different ideas about how to fix it
so there might be something there's
probably something wrong about that
scene you know even if their solutions
are poor and and and so it's worth
thinking about that stuff and and and
you know and I mean the which the first
draft of the which that was presentable
there is no central protagonist it was
we would fought we followed each of the
family members carefully for a period of
time and then the film ended with
Thomason and my producing partners were
kind of like look it's cool we think
it's cool
it probably cannot be financed it might
be the best version of this movie what
you're doing but but we think it may
never get financed if you do it like
this if you have a central protagonist I
think we can finance this movie and I
was very upset about it again like at
that time like incredibly defensive but
I thought okay I can make it about
Thomasin and I can deal with that you
know one of the things I don't love
about the witch though as I think there
are these kinds of you can feel that the
original version wasn't only her you
know and there's good things about that
as far as like the world-building is
concerned but there's bad things about
that as far as like having the best
narrative you could have then when you
at that point go into filming with kind
of script that maybe you're 80 90
percent happy with I was happy to be
script at the time you know now I have
my things but it was I mean I had many
years because no one to finance it for
so long like I had many years to like
get it in pretty good shape I liked the
script better than the film I'm gonna
ask a very superficial question about
writing in animals so you had the goat
in the woods which I believe was kind of
hunt troublesome and then seagulls
feature very heavily in the lighthouse
did you think when you're writing that
how I'm gonna orchestrate yeah so now
now I'm very very very cautious about
writing animals not that I don't do it
but I do a lot of research about like
can these animals be trained are they
legal to shoot within the countries I'm
most likely to be shooting and like who
trains them what can they do all this
stuff before I do that so I didn't do
that with the witch the goat was a
nightmare and and you can't train a goat
and don't write a goat in your movie is
my biggest tip of the night unless
they're just supposed to like stand
around and eat stuff they're not
supposed to eat and so then my Brooke
like I wanted Pattison's character
killing a sea bird to be like the the
catalyst that would bring the storm
but my my and that inspired my brother
to write all these [ __ ] scenes of
seagulls and he was telling me about it
and I was like there's no way I'm going
to do that no you know and then he was
like I urge you to read these scenes I
think they're good and they were great
so I so we had to have a seagull but the
great news is like seagulls are are
incredibly intelligent and there's three
very well trained seagulls in the UK so
you know right right seagulls right
right way I want to thank you so much
for giving a phenomenal lecture for
creating two wonderful pieces of cinema
I know that we're all really excited to
see what you do now thank you Robert
Edgar
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]